للمدن الكبرى كلمه الفصل بتحديد هويه
الرئيس الحاكم للبلاد وهذا ما حصل فعلا في
تركيا فغير التصويت في المدن الكبرى نتائج
وقلب موازين القوى كما ادخل البلاد في
جوله رئاسيه ثانيه بين الحزب الحاكم
وتحالف المعارضه الخريطه هنا توضح
مشاهدينا ان المنافسه احتدمت بين اردوغان
واوجلو في مدينتي انقره التي لها طبعا
دلالات رمزيه على النظام المتبع في البلاد
واسطنبول التي تعتبر قلب تركيا الاقتصاديه
النابض فالعاصمه انقره انقلبت على الرئيس
الحالي وتفوق فيها اوغلو باكثر من 47%
مقابل 46% لاردوغان اسطنبول بدورها اعطت
ايضا الغلبه للمعارضه بنسبه تفوق الثمانيه
والاربعين بالمئه في وقت حصل فيها اردوغان
على نسبه المزيد عن 46% كما نشاهد هنا مما
ادى الى تراجعه الى مدون الخمسين نقطه اما
المفاجاه الكبرى فكانت في مناطق الزلزال
وهي 11 ولايه ابرزها كما هو معلوم غازي عن
تاب واضنه وهاتاي التي تعتبر معاقل
المعارضه تقدم فيها اردوغان بشكل كبير
امام غريمه حيث صوتت مدينه هاتاي لاردوغان
باربعين او 48% مقابل 48 بالمئه فصل سبعه
اي بفارق 300 صوت فقط كما نشاهد هنا
بالنتائج بين الفريقين
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات